hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out a little something here
from sony i'm really excited about this
these are the sony console faceplates
these are the official ones from sony i
have two colors here we've got the
cosmic red and the midnight black now i
was one of the people that was like
super fan girl like i absolutely love
the white playstation console now that
i'm kind of like looking at my setup
that i have all my consoles are all
black except for the new nintendo switch
dock which is white which actually was
kind of working out because there was a
nice little alternating pattern
happening there with the playstation
this is gonna look a lot better and a
lot sleeker inside of there we've also
got the new colorful controllers this
does this have like a special name to it
or is it just like pink because it's
it's pink it's pink we're calling it
pink and we've got a blue and
the purple dude like these look so good
hi
beautiful
look how good especially this pink one
oh no no
they'll also have corresponding matching
face plates to go with all of the
controllers i do have the matching
controllers to go to these but they are
actually back in pennsylvania because i
had them shipped there those are now
like my pennsylvania controllers when
i'm back home visiting my family that's
like i just seen problems right there oh
my east coast playstation controllers
aren't here to show you how well they
match with the faceplates let's open up
the controllers first i need a knife i
need a knife please hold
look at this stuff
isn't it neat pink is so pretty i
definitely want to get the face plate
that matches a huge thank you though to
sony for sending me these to check out
i'm so so so excited
the box looked nice wow pink no look at
this oh my god it's beautiful like this
is something that i just want to like
set out and like display the sheer
absolute beauty of this oh my god it's
incredible i love it
oh
so this is like my sister's favorite
color i feel like the okay i mean this
is absolutely beautiful and it's
stunning but like this is my sister's
color and this is my color it's so funny
because like these are both of our exact
favorite colors and then in the middle
of these we've got the purple it's hard
to say like what my favorite color is
like i think pink and black are like my
two favorite colors i know black is a
shade it's not actually a color but i'm
not here to have a discussion about
color theory purple used to be my
favorite accent color some of you may
remember if you've been around long
enough that i had a custom camo
purple camo pc
is absolutely
the coolest
like this is the exact color of that pc
too
like this is awesome these are such good
colors
freaking stunning
stunning i could just sit here and
admire them for for all of the days
we've got the controllers unboxed and
now we have the face plates i feel like
i'm just getting back into
the video making process for the new
year
i hope i'm even recording we are so i
wonder how these go on if it just snaps
over top or do i have to like fully
replace that is the
question directions
where step one oh okay one two and three
are saying that i have to turn off
the console so like yeah i already did
that remove the top cover by slightly
pulling up on the direction of the arrow
all right let's do it slightly pulling
up
i'm scared
i'm i'm so i'm so scared right now
dude i'm i'm stressing
this is terrifying this is absolutely
okay that's already kind of ouch though
[Music]
i'm so scared i don't want to break it
you're going to put your hand behind it
like this put your fingers behind here
at the same time so let me show you okay
it's actually a lot easier than i
thought pull up and slide down at the
same time
wow we did it is my microphone still on
or did i knock it free
yeah so definitely those are that's why
it slides it's just like a little
sliding mechanism
that's it dude freaking what the heck
look how good this looks oh
wow
pull up
and slide okay it's actually it's pretty
easy i feel as though i have
made it look a little more difficult
than it is but it's really not oh my god
this is so sleek so
good check
check it
like can you even
oh
boy
this red also
is so nice it's almost
like a kind of like a pinkish color it's
not quite
this pink god i'm so scared to put this
back on pull up and slide
see yeah
totally
simple
oh even like oh this is like a real
marquez look that'll come off
i'm just afraid of hurting my thingies
my little pinkies there we go that's way
easier after i've done it
once or twice this is beautiful this is
beautiful
sony you guys did a freaking great job
so i'd love to know from you guys which
color controller is your favorite the
original
white one that came with the console do
you prefer these super bright colors or
do you prefer the cosmic red or the
midnight black i actually had my little
niece she unboxed the the two
playstation controllers and man she had
like the best time ever show them there
you go can you say cosmic lick red
blonde can you say black black can you
say midnight night can you say midnight
black name love
can you say playstation
yeah she's now taking
taking them away
taking them to dad
can you say bye
excited to check this out again a huge
thank you to sony for sending me these
so that i can get a chance to show them
to you wow hyped about this pink let's
just take one more quick little look at
that just like that's beautiful
absolutely stunning well thank you guys
for watching i'll see you in my next
video if there's anything that you'd
like to see me cover here on my channel
this year leave it in the comments below
i also have brought back my discord
server it's actually a joint server with
my sister it's called same brain so i'll
put a little link below you guys can go
check that out and we've been having so
much fun chatting over there i just
rebooted it like this past week so we're
still kind of like in the process um my
hair keeps getting stuck in this
milanese loop apple watch band you may
have seen it happening throughout this
whole video stop it stop it please all
right i'm gonna go see you later bye